give me the
the i guess the difference between you
know
the asian section of where you're from
and then like what is the difference
between the
like obviously historically we think of
crypts from long beach
they look a certain way and and people
who aren't from
long beach or who don't who aren't aware
of the asian
presence right like if you're someone
who's from like [ __ ] wichita kansas
and you're like wait there's
asian crips you know what i'm saying
like what is the difference
and it if if any and like how does how
does it kind of fit into the
the grand scheme of of everything when
it comes to that [ __ ] without getting
like obviously
too too into it well you know like um
how we formed was because the uh
cambodian khmer rouge
war which is very slept on they only
know about like hitler and
the holocaust and [ __ ] like that but it
was killing the ruler cambodia was
killing millions of our people
like millions he just wanted to
eliminate everybody and they were doing
that and it was like one point something
million cambodia's getting killed
through the whole country
and no it was very slept on it and i
forgot what president
what year was this this is like the 70s
[ __ ]
so then like late 70s so then
my dad and she was already born and [ __ ]
over there my mom
they were young very young kids and then
um i forgot what president was at the
time i don't know
oh reagan or all right reagan or jimmy
jimmy carter maybe reagan if it was
reagan or somebody early 80s late 70s
it's like reagan jimmy carter yeah i'm
thinking reagan but
i could be wrong don't quote me on it
but they were they helped out and they
went over there and they brought us over
here and then some you know they brought
i think the vietnam via vietnam helped
us but they brought us over here and the
large
there were two places where a large um
group of cambodians went to the number
one were the most ones it was long beach
california and then the second one was
boston massachusetts that's where we
have a hood as well and it was just like
we came over here and the other races
the blacks and hispanics in long beach
wasn't used to us
but we were mainly beefing with the
hispanics and then the blacks was
already beefing with the hispanics and
then their blacks were crips and long
beach is the only city in the u.s
whereas all [ __ ] city there's not one
blood hood you know what i'm saying is
that you
a [ __ ] or you're a south side or a
mexican you know
so we we adapted to their community and
became crips that's how people
and then it just spread like wildfire
and we're different because we're just
like
oh no we just programmed different i
don't think yeah how disconnected is the
long beach politics from like la
politics because you know obviously and
even in the valley there's like pacoima
and you know it's it's very it's very
disconnected we're like well us
is disconnected but it's kind of like
our neighborhood is
like our like my neighborhood from in
long beach was also in
the sfv was in van nuys they were also
in san gabriel valley they're also in
orange county
so like they beef with those
neighborhoods which brings it to us
because it's like you be for one you be
for all you know what i'm saying
but then it's like it's disconnected but
it's kind of connected it's like you
know what i'm saying
do you have do you feel like um being
like like do you are you do you feel
like you're a role model for like young
young kids that look like you out of
your city yeah
for sure do you take that like to the
heart because i feel like you know
when you you really can you know maybe
steer some kids the right direction
yeah i kind of want them to be do be
like you could be successful
without getting locked up or end up dead
and and being
you could be cool because everyone as a
kid want to be do what everyone is doing
be the cool kids you know what i'm
saying
you could be cool and and successful in
without taking the same path i took you
know what i'm saying
yeah like i think that you know
obviously we all are where we are
because of our life experiences and you
bro probably shouldn't regret much in
life you know what i'm saying but
you know if you could help steer uh
steer somebody a different direction
because you already walked that path for
them you know what i mean
yeah for sure